>> Leslie: this is our "inGraham
angle" special town hall,
Chicago, a city in crisis.
we have the airways consumed,
it's easy to forget the crisis
unfolding on America's streets
and the process being ignored as
we retreat in our political
corners.
we were here in Chicago a year
ago.
at that time we promised the
>> Sean: PEOPLE IN THE
COMMUNITIES AND OUR OFFICE IN
GENERAL THAT WE'D BE BACK AND
NOT LET THE ISSUES GO.
AND TONIGHT, WE'RE HERE TO
FULFILL THAT PROMISE.
WE RETURNED TO ASSESS HOW LIFE
IS CHANGED OR NOT FOR THE
VIOLENCE PLAGUED NEIGHBORHOODS.
AND WHETHER THE RELATIONSHIP
BETWEEN THE COMMUNITIES AND LAW
ENFORCEMENT, WHETHER IT'S
IMPROVED OR WORSENED THE CITY
WAS BRUTALIZED BY GUN VIOLENCE
AND BLOODSHED AND WHAT ARE
POLITICAL LEADERS DOING ABOUT
IT?
LAST YEAR, RAHME EMMANUEL WAS
FINISHING HIS FINAL YEAR AS
MAYOR AND NOW MAYOR LORIE
LIGHTFOOT IS FACING A NUMBER OF
CHALLENGES, A LOOMING TEACHER
STRIKE, UNACCEPTABLE LEVEL OF
GANG AND DRUG VIOLENCE, AND A
CITY RUNNING OUT OF PATIENCE.
WE'LL EXPLORE ALL OF IT WITH OUR
LIVE AUDIENCE AND EXPERT PANELS.
BUT I WANT YOU TO UNDERSTAND
WHAT'S HAPPENING IN THE AREA WE
ARE BROADCASTING FROM TONIGHT.
WE'RE HERE AT NEW BEGINNINGS
CHURCH AND IT'S SITUATED IN ONE
OF THE MOST DANGEROUS
NEIGHBORHOODS ON CHICAGO'S SOUTH
SIDE.
DO YOU SEE THE RED CIRCLES ON
THAT MAP?
WELL, THOSE ARE THE HOMICIDES
THAT HAVE OCCURRED JUST THIS
YEAR ALONE.
AND CHILDREN ARE TOO OFTEN THE
VICTIMS OF THE VIOLENCE HERE IN
CHICAGO AS OUR OWN RAYMOND
ARROYO FOUND ON THE SOUTH SIDE
OF TOWN.
>> WE'RE A FEW MILES FROM
TONIGHT'S TOWN HALL IN HARVEY.
NOW, THE VIOLENCE IS INTENSE AND
TO GIVE YOU A SENSE OF HOW
INTENSE THE VIOLENCE IS, IN THE
CITY OF CHICAGO, THERE HAVE BEEN
300 HOMICIDE PLUS JUST THIS
YEAR.
OVER 1600 SHOOTINGS, AND TO
BRING IT HOME FOR PEOPLE IN THIS
COMMUNITY, THE HOUSE BEHIND ME
BELONGS TO KENTVANIA, SHE'S 12
YEARS OLD.
EARLIER THIS WEEK, SHE WAS
MAKING PLANS FOR HER BIRTHDAY
PARTY.
HER FAMILY WAS WATCHING THE
BEAR'S GAME, WHEN AROUND 9:00 AT
NIGHT, A GROUP OF MEN APPROACHED
THE HOUSE AND BULLETS STARTED
FLYING, HER FAMILY HIT THE DECK
AND SHE DIDN'T GET UP.
A BULLET PIERCED THE FRONT
WINDOW AND STRUCK HER IN THE
BACK OF THE HEAD.
SHE DIED ON HER BIRTHDAY.
THE COMMUNITY IS STILL SHAKEN.
>> WE HEARD IT.
MY DAUGHTER WAS IN THE BACK OF
THE HOUSE.
TOLD HER TO GET DOWN.
AND I CAME OUT AFTER THEY WERE
OUT AND THEY WERE CRYING AND
STUFF AND SINGING AND HOLLERING,
THAT COULD HAPPEN TO US.
JUST RANDOM SHOOTING.
>> EVERYONE JUST -- I HEAR
THEY'RE NOT SLEEPING WELL.
IT'S JUST BAD.
>> SHOULDN'T HAVE TO ACTUALLY
SEE THIS TYPE OF VIOLENCE, EVER.
PRETTY MUCH ALL QUESTION DO IS
JUST PRAY.
>> I'VE BEEN HERE ALL MY LIFE.
IT'S JUST NOT LIKE IT USED TO BE
WHERE I GREW UP.
>> DO YOU BRING THE KIDS IN
EARLY ENOUGH?
>> OH, YEAH.
THEY STAY RIGHT HERE.
NOWHERE ELSE.
>> WHO DO YOU BLAME FOR THIS?
>> POLICE PRESENCE, RIDING
AROUND, SEEING WHAT'S GOING ON
IN THE COMMUNITY.
GET OUT, MEET THE PEOPLE.
>> IT'S AFFECTING EVERYONE AT
THEIR CORE HERE.
THERE'S NOT A SINGLE THING OF
GUNS, YOU KNOW, GUN RIGHTS,
WHATEVER.
IT'S NOT JUST A SINGLE THING OF
JUST THAT.
IT'S A -- IT'S A GAMBIT OF
THING, A LOT OF THINGS THAT COME
IN THIS POT.
>> I'VE BEEN HERE 50 SOME YEARS.
I RAISED MY KIDS HERE.
I AM SCARED.
>> SO FAR THIS YEAR, HOMICIDE
ARE TRACKING AT A SLOWER PACE
THAN THEY WERE IN 2018.
BUT THEY'RE STILL NEAR THE TOP
FOR AN AMERICAN CITY, LAST YEAR,
EXCEEDING THE MURDER RATES ABOVE
NEW YORK AND L.A.
BUT FOR THE PEOPLE IN THESE
AT-RISK COMMUNITIES, THE
STATISTIC, THEY DON'T MEAN ALL
THAT MUCH.
THEY'RE SUFFERING FROM
UNACCEPTABLE LEVELS OF ROUTINE
VIOLENCE.
JOINING ME NOW IS TONY ROBINSON,
FORMER CHICAGO POLICE OFFICER IN
THE VIOLENT CRIMES DIVISION,
FORMER HOMICIDE DETECTIVE,
JOSEPH MOSELEY, AND A FORMER
HOMICIDE DETECTIVE AND 30-YEAR
VETERAN OF THE CHICAGO POLICE
DEPARTMENT, AND ANTHONY
WILLIAMS, PASTOR AND ACTIVIST
HERE IN CHICAGO.
TONY, I WANT TO START WITH YOU.
IT'S HARD TO WATCH THAT STORY.
THE FACTS.
THE PROMISE OF A YOUNG GIRL CUT
SHORT NEEDLESSLY.
SHE'S, ONE, THOUGH, OF HUNDREDS
UPON HUNDREDS OF AFTERRY  --
AFRICAN-AMERICAN YOUTH THAT GET
CAUGHT UP IN THIS TYPE OF
VIOLENCE.
PEOPLE WATCHING TONIGHT SAY WHAT
DO WE DO?
HOW DO WE STOP THIS?
>> WE CANNOT POLICE OUR WAY OUT
OF THIS.
THIS HAS TO COME FROM THE
COMMUNITY.
AND BEING A HOMICIDE DETECTIVE,
IT HURTS ME JUST AS MUCH WHEN I
CAN'T SOLVE THAT PROBLEM.
WHEN I CANNOT GET MEMBERS OF THE
COMMUNITY, WHO KNOWS?
AND I UNDERSTAND IT, BECAUSE
THEY HAVE TO LIVE THERE.
THEY DON'T WANT TO TALK TO THE
POLICE.
WE NEED TO BACK OUR PROGRAMS
THAT WE USED TO HAVE ON THE
POLICE DEPARTMENT LIKE OFFICER
FRIENDLY.
THE EXPLORER SCOUTS, TAKE THE
YOUTH, GIVE THEM SOMETHING TO
DO.
WE HAVE TO REALLY BE INVOLVED
WITH OUR COMMUNITY AND OUR
YOUTH.
WHEN I WORKED THERE FOR 29
YEARS, EVERYBODY THAT KNEW ME
KNEW I WAS A GOOD COP.
AND I WORKED MY BUTT OFF.
I CONTINUE TO VOLUNTEER, GO TO
THE ACADEMY, TALK TO OUR YOUNG
RECRUITS.
POLICING IS A STATE OF MIND, NOT
A STATE OF BEING.
YOU CAN'T JUST PUT SOMEONE OFF
OF THE STREET AND SAY YOU EAR
THE POLICE.
THEY COMPLAIN ABOUT TRAINING.
YOU KNOW SOMETHING?
DO WHAT YOU WERE TRAINED TO DO.
TREAT PEOPLE WITH EMPATHY.
BE FAIR.
AND UNDERSTAND THAT JUST BECAUSE
SOMEONE LIVES IN A PROJECT OR A
TORN-DOWN NEIGHBORHOOD, THEY
DON'T HAVE THAT MENTALITY.
AND IT'S JUST A VERY FEW PEOPLE
THAT'S IN OUR COMMUNITY THAT
RAISES ALL OF THIS CONFUSION.
>> WE'RE GOING TO GET BACK TO
YOUR SON WHO IS NOW A NEW POLICE
OFFICER.
>> GOD BLESS HIM.
>> IN CHICAGO.
YOU DIDN'T EVEN KNOW HE WAS
APPLYING FOR THE ACADEMY?
>> I HAD NO IDEA.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
[ APPLAUSE ]
>> I WANT TO GO TO YOU.
YOU'RE AN ACTIVIST.
YOU'VE BEEN ENGAGED HERE AS A
COMMUNITY ACTIVIST FOR YEARS AND
YEARS.
PEOPLE SAY, WELL, IT'S GETTING
BETTER, BE PATIENT.
IT'S OKAY, IT'S GETTING BETTER,
IT'S TRENDING BETTER.
DO YOU FEEL  THAT?
AND DO YOU UNDERSTAND WHAT TONY
SAID, IT'S NOT A POLICING
PROBLEM, IT'S A COMMUNITY
PROBLEM.
>> I LOST A SON TO VIOLENCE
FEBRUARY 21, 2018, JEREMIAH
WILLIAMS.
VIOLENCE IS THE NUMBER ONE
PROBLEM OF THE 21st CENTURY.
WHAT WE DID -- OUR RESPONSE WAS
TO TALK WITH OUR STATE
REPRESENTATIVES FOR NINE DAYS.
WE HAD A RESOLUTION PASSED.
VIOLENCE IS A HEALTH CRISES,
WE'RE PREPARING TO WALK TO
SPRINGFIELD ON OCTOBER 14.
THE GOAL IS TO PASS
COMPREHENSIVE LEGISLATION ON
VIOLENCE AS A HELP CRISES AND A
DISEASE.
THE SYSTEM OF VIOLENCE IS
OVERWHELMING.
WE ALL AS CITIZENS MUST DEAL
WITH THIS LEVIATHAN, THE ISSUE
OF VIOLENCE IS EVERYONE'S FIGHT.
HISTORY SHOWS US THAT IN
AMERICA, YOU WANT TO COME AT
JUSTICE ON EVIL LEGISLATION.
WE CAN'T LEGISLATE OURSELVES OUT
OF THIS, POLICE OURSELVES OUT OF
THIS, BUT WE NEED CIVILITY RIGHT
NOW.
CIVILITY IS IMPORTANT.
VIOLENCE AIN'T COOL.
CIVILITY IS -- IS POWERFUL.
THIS IS THE HUMAN HEALTH CRISES.
NO ONE IS SAFE NO MATTER WHERE
YOU LIVE.
SO, WE ARE WORKING TOWARDS
COMPREHENSIVE LEGISLATION.
>> INVOLVING WHAT?
>> COMPREHENSIVE LEGISLATION
WILL BE UNDER HEALTH CARE.
THE CDC HAS SAID THAT VIOLENCE
IS A DISEASE.
BUT IT'S NOT A CONTAGIOUS.
WE DO NOT NEED VACCINES.
BUT WE NEED COMPREHENSIVE
LEGISLATION.
SAME THING LIKE CIGARETTES, IT'S
ALMOST UN-AMERICAN NOT TO SMOKE
AT A BAR BUT YOU CAN'T SMOKE IN
A BAR ANYMORE, WHY?
BECAUSE IT'S THE LAW.
IT'S THE LAW THAT MOVES THE
NEEDLE.
WHEN DR. KING AND OTHERS GOT
TOGETHER, WE NEEDED AN END GAME.
WE'RE DEALING WITH THE DEMON OF
SEGREGATION, LEGISLATION.
THIS IS JUST ONE OF MANY
METHODS.
I WORK TOWARDS SOLUTION.
WE KNOW ABOUT THE PROBLEM.
BUT WE CAME ALONG AND WITH OUR
LEGISLATORS, WE'RE ABOUT TO HAVE
A GAME CHANGER THAT'S GOING TO
DEAL WITH THE ISSUE OF VIOLENCE
LIKE NEVER BEFORE.
>> JOSEPH, STEVE, POLICE, TRUST,
DISTRUST LEVEL, COMMUNITY TO
POLICE.
GALLUP POLL SHOWING THIS IN
CHICAGO.
IT'S NOT GREAT.
THEY EITHER KNOW SOMEONE OR
THEY, THEMSELVES, HAVE HAD A BAD
INTERACTION WITH POLICE.
HOW DO YOU AS A FORMER POLICE
OFFICER FEEL WHEN YOU HEAR THAT?
BECAUSE AS WE HEARD FROM TONY,
THIS IS A -- THIS IS A
COMMITMENT -- TO BE A POLICE
OFFICER IN TODAY'S DAY AND AGE,
BEING OUTGUNNED AND OFTENTIMES
UNDERSTAFFED, YOU'RE -- YOU'RE
DEALING WITH THE DIFFICULT
HURDLES TO CLEAR, YET, THE
COMMUNITY NEEDS YOU.
>> WELL, WELL, I THINK THE
PROBLEM THERE IS WE MISIDENTIFY
WHAT THE REAL PROBLEMS ARE.
AS MY LEARNED COLLEAGUE SAID,
YOU CANNOT LEGISLATE YOURSELF
OUT OF THIS.
YOU CAN'T DELEGATE YOUR WAY OUT
OF IT.
HOWEVER, WE HAVE TO TAKE A MORE
WHOLISTIC APPROACH.
UNDERSTAND THIS IS A MENTAL
HEALTH CRISIS.
UNDERSTAND THAT WE'RE LOOKING AT
ANOTHER GROUP OF SECOND
GENERATION CRACK BABIES, LOOKING
AT LEARNING DISORDERS.
SO WE HAVE TO LOOK AT THIS FROM
A WHOLISTIC APPROACH AND SAY
WHAT ELSE DO WE DO.
AND UNDERSTAND THAT A LOT OF
POLICE OFFICERS HAVE A BIG
MISUNDERSTANDING OF WHAT THEIR
JOB IS.
WE ARE SOCIAL WORKERS.
FOR ALL INTENTS AND PURPOSES,
FOR ALL OF THE RHETORIC THAT YOU
HEAR, WE DON'T GET OUT OF THE
CAR WITH THE GUN OUT.
YOU'RE SUPPOSED TO GET OUT THERE
TO HELP PEOPLE.
PLAIN AND SIMPLE -- SERVE AND
PROTECT.
NOT JUST PROTECT THE OTHER
PROBLEM IS WE HAVE TO HAVE A
PARADIGM SHIFT WITHIN THE POLICE
DEPARTMENT.
IT HAS TO HAVE ANOTHER FACE THAT
SAYS, LISTEN, EVERYONES NOT YOUR
ENEMY.
>> ABC NEWS REPORTING LAST WEEK,
DANGEROUS WEEK LEAVES CHICAGO
POLICE OFFICERS BESIEGED BY
VIOLENCE.
A VETERAN OFFICER WAS HOT AND
CRITICALLY WOUNDED.
WITH TWO COLLAPSED LUNGS AND
FRACTURED RIBS.
I WANT TO RETURN NOW TO THE
CURRENT LEADER OF THE CITY,
MAYOR -- EXCUSE ME, LORI
LIGHTFOOT.
WE INVITED HER TO BE PART OF THE
TOWN HALL.
THE CITY HALL IS JUST A FEW
MILES FROM HERE.
SHE'S VERY BUSY.
BUT SHE DECLINED OUR INVITATION.
THAT'S OKAY.
BUT ESPECIALLY WITH THE
IMPENDING TEACHER STRIKE,
THERE'S A LOT GOING ON.
I DO HOPE SHE JOIN US ON THE
SHOW ANOTHER TIME BACK IN
WASHINGTON.
THE DOOR IS OPEN.
SHE HAS AN OPEN INVITATION.
YESTERDAY MAYOR LIGHTFOOT DID
TAKE TIME OUT OF HER SCHEDULE TO
ASSAIL U.S. IMMIGRATION
OFFICIALS.
I.C.E. HAS BEGUN A MAJOR EFFORT
TO REMOVE CRIMINAL ALIENS FROM
THE STREET ALSO ADDING TO SOME
OF THE PROBLEMS HERE.
THE MAYOR RATHER THAN WELCOMING
THE EFFORTS CHOSE TO DEFEND HER
CITY'S SANCTUARY POLICIES THAT
HINDER FEDERAL LAW ENFORCEMENT.
>> WE ARE NOT GOING TO TOLERATE
LETTING I.C.E. TERRORIZE OUR
IMMIGRANT AND REFUGEE
COMMUNITIES.
WE WILL NEVER EVER SUCCUMB TO
THE RACIST, XENOPHOBIC RHETORIC
OF I.C.E.
WE WILL CONTINUE TO BAN I.C.E.
FROM HAVING ACCESS TO ANY C.P.D.
DATA BASES, WE'LL NOT ALLOW ANY
C.P.D. OFFICER TO COOPERATE WITH
ANYTHING RELATED TO KRICHLT E.
AND THE IMMIGRATION RATES.
>> POLICE OFFICERS I TALK TO
SAID THAT MAKES OUR LIVES HARDER
BECAUSE NOW I.C.E. HAS TO GO TO
THE COMMUNITIES TO LOOK FOR THE
CRIMINALS.
THESE ARE NOT MOTHERS AND
FATHERS IN RESTAURANTS, THESE
ARE CRIMINAL ELEMENTS IN GANGS,
PUSHING THE MS13 IN GANGS, ALL
OF THE LATIN KINGS IN THESE
NEIGHBORHOODS.
NOW I.C.E. HAS TO GO THERE, THEY
CAN'T ARREST THEM OUTSIDE OF A
COURTROOM.
WHAT ARE YOUR THOUGHTS?
>> LET ME BE PERFECTLY CLEAR FOR
ANYBODY IN THIS AUDIENCE, I'M A
BLACK MAN FIRST, I'M A POLICE
OFFICER SECOND.
I WAS A VICTIM OF THE POLICE
BRUTALITY.
THAT'S WHY I JOINED THE POLICE
DEPARTMENT.
THEN I HAD TO SUE THE POLICE
DEPARTMENT TO GET ON BECAUSE I
WAS DISCRIMINATED AGAINST.
SO ALL MY CAREER HAS BEEN
UPHOLDING THE LAW.
AND IF SOMEONE IS BREAKING THE
LAW, I WOULDN'T CARE WHO THEY
ARE, IF THEY ARE ILLEGAL, IF
THEY ARE LEGAL, I'M GOING TO
ASSIST.
ANY OF THE OTHER AGENCIES THAT
COME IN HERE.
>> JOSEPH, DOESN'T THAT JUST
MAKE SENSE?
THESE ARE CRIMINAL ILLEGAL
ALIENS WHO ARE RUNNING DRUGS,
NARCOTICS RINGS, GANGS, INSIDE
THE CITY.
AND THE MAYOR IS SAYING, NO, WE
WILL NOT COOPERATE WITH FEDERAL
AUTHORITIES HERE.
>> I THINK FOR ME THE BIGGEST
PROBLEM IS THAT PEOPLE -- OR
THAT WE -- ALL OF US IN THIS
ROOM USE THE TERM "COMMON
SENSE."
IF COMMON SENSE WAS SO COMMON,
THERE WOULD BE NO NEED FOR THIS.
SO I'LL LEAVE IT AT THAT.
[ APPLAUSE ]
>> ALL OF YOU, TONY, ANTHONY,